- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
I believe in people more than
they believe in themselves.
My sincere hope is that if you see in you
what I see in you, you'll go
off and change the planet.
I started the Believe Love series because
having a relationship can be hard.
And especially hard for entrepreneurs
because we are managing
a child in our business
and also a relationship.
I thought it'd be of great value to myself
and also to you guys to share some advice,
some expertise and knowledge from people
who are having successful
businesses and careers
and also relationships and marriages
and how to make it all work together.
Today we're going to learn
from Jada and Will Smith
and their message of don't quit.
- I know who's here with me tonight.
- After 20 years, she knows your scent.
- I know the touch, I know the scent,
I know the energy, everything.
- I told her, we were
just talking about that.
I said, "That look of love that I saw
"when you all walked onto
this carpet, my goodness."
- You know, Jada, 'cause we've survived.
- We have, we've survived.
- That's the thing that is difficult
that people don't understand about love.
You think it's all flowers and everything
but love gets created
by making it together.
It's like it's from survival.
- We've come through some stuff.
- This is a gangster right
here in front of you all.
This little one here a gangster.
(laughing)
Ride or die.
- It can't be easy always
to make a relationship work.
You talked about recently,
marriage being a hard thing to work on.
What did you mean by that?
- Everything that you do that's
great is going to be difficult.
The most difficult part
about a relationship
is that it's really not between two people
that makes it work.
It's between you and you.
What Jada and I have learned
is bettering ourselves
individually is how you
make a relationship work.
If you're going to have counseling,
marriage counseling isn't
always the way to go.
Individual counseling,
you get yourself together,
and present yourself to your partner
in a higher spiritual and emotional state
and you'd be surprised how
much better things can go.
If there is a secret, I would say,
is that we never went into
working on our relationship.
We only ever worked on
ourselves individually
and then presented
ourselves to one another
better than we were previously.
If you don't have a goal,
if you don't have a purpose
for your relationship
and pretty much anything.
It's, like, if you don't have a purpose,
if you don't have a
place that you're going,
something that you want to accomplish,
something you want to do,
you can really get lost in
the murk of the journey.
- There has to be a vision for--
- There has to be a vision, right.
So, why are we together?
I mean, you fine, you fine, you know.
But as an answer for why two
spirits would join together
and decide to travel this perilous journey
of life together.
Fine or you can cook or you
keep the house protected,
that's really not enough.
There's so much more that
you have to be dedicated to.
- Will and I are very
relaxed with one another.
I think because from how
I've answered questions of,
"Girl, what would you do if he came home
"and this and that and that."
Or, "Being married to a
big superstar like Will,
"how do you deal with other women?"
My answer's always,
"I've always told Will,
"you can do
"whatever you want
"as long as you can look
at yourself in the mirror
"and be okay."
Because at the end of the
day, Will is his own man.
I'm here as his partner
but he is his own man.
He has to decide who he wants to be
and that's not for me to do for him.
Or vice versa.
- I'm a hopeless romantic.
I've made the distinction
between romance and love.
Real love is born of
surviving with someone
where you develop true love.
- In that have a certain
understanding of what is needed.
I think that with marriages,
people have to understand
that you have to look at your marriage
and understand what is
needed in your marriage.
Not what people think
your marriage should be.
Not what people want your marriage to be.
But I have to look at my husband
and I have to look at him
and look at what he needs
as an individual.
He has to look at me and see what I need.
Then we have to look at the union
and see what the union needs.
We have to make decisions based on that.
Not based on what people
think marriage should be.
- I got to just ask out of personal,
'cause you guys are such a cool couple,
another anniversary, was it, recently?
That is so cool.
What advice, I got little kids,
only been married a little bit,
what advice could you pass
on to your boy right here?
- Just stay in it.
- Just keep on trucking.
(laughing)
'Cause you got little kids
so I know what that's about.
It gets real.
- It becomes about them
but you can't forget
about you either, right?
- Marriages go through many
different cycles and stages.
It gets better and better and better.
You will go through some tough patches,
some really bad ones that are
going to make you want to quit,
going to make you want to quit, but don't.
- She's about making
about to cry right now.
(laughing) Okay.
- And you want to kill,
makes you want to kill him.
(laughing)
- That is real talk.
- I love it, real talk.
- Just stay in, just stay in.
- All right, all right.
I'm going to go pray about that tonight.
- We've been married 20 years.
We've been asking ourself that question.
Really, at the end of the
day, it's just not quitting.
You can't expect it to be easy.
Our marriage was the
most difficult, grueling,
and excruciating thing
that we've ever taken on
in our lives.
We're just not quitters
and by the same token,
we're not apathetic.
So, we're not going to sit
there and let it, you know.
- In those same pictures,
I love seeing you and Will.
You guys have got what everybody wants.
So, what is the secret?
How do you guys always look
like you're on honeymoon?
- You know what, it's
really just friendship.
I have to tell you.
It's like your partner has
to be your best, best friend.
And he's my best friend.
- How do you keep things so,
I keep reading that the
pair of you have this,
sort of, fantastic sex life
(Jada laughs)
after 14 years of marriage.
- You have to.
I know people get so upset
about it, but, for me--
- I don't, I get excited by it.
What I read was that wherever
you go, the pair of you,
you try and make love.
Is this true?
- We've made love in
some interesting places.
- Should I be concerned
about my green room?
- You should be.
(Piers laughing)
You should be.
The thing about it is
that I feel like you have
to keep spontaneity.
You have to keep your
partner on their toes
because once it starts
getting into a routine,
it's like, it gets very boring.
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ The way you love me make me want to say
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ Girl, the way you
look make me want to say
♫ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
♫ Just who you are make me want to say
♫ Need you more but it's like
Picasso painted your aura
♫ It's like Beethoven
composed your vocal tones
♫ Rodin-inspired hands
sculpted you the desire of man
♫ Maya Angelou breathes inside you
♫ Seeds of my wildest dreams
fertilize in your eyes
♫ You're compassionate
and you're passionate
♫ It's how ration it
♫ That make me swear you was
trained how to take me there
♫ Rarely, I seen fate be fair
♫ We got a stroke of grace
♫ 'Member you was countin' me out
♫ It's crazy we had times of doubt, right
♫ Since the dawn of time, writ in history
♫ Better men, better poets than me
♫ Have tried to set verse
to the love they knew
♫ Dead to words, judge
what I do want to give you
♫ All my love
♫ A thousand kisses from you
♫ Never too much, never
too much, never too much
♫ I just don't want to stop
♫ Big Will
♫ Lil' Jade
♫ 2002, Tra-Knox
♫ All my love
♫ Everything I got, baby
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What was your favorite
message in this video?
How are you going to apply
it to your life somehow?
Is this series helpful to you?
And do you want to see it continue or not?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really, really curious
to see what you have to say.
Thank you guys, again,
so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.